(rock music)
- Now it's time for
tonight's hashtag wars.
(applause)
Hannibal!
- Oh The Places You'll Go
When You Need to Score Cocaine.
- Points, yes of course, Eliza.
- The Lion, the Witch
and the War Crimes.
- [Chris] Points!
Kamau.
- Goodnight (censored).
(laughter)
- [Chris] Points!
Eliza.
- Amelia Pedophilia.
- Yeah, points!
Yes, uh Hannibal.
- The Hardy Boys
Bang Judy Blume.
- [Chris] Todd.
- M'n'emphysemus.
- Yes, points, I like it, Jenny.
- Roofies n' Cream.
- Yes, points!
Mike Lawrence.
- Dia-Reese's Pieces.
(laughter)
- Those were ET's
favorite, points.
Uh, Mike, again.
- Somali Ranchers.
(laughter)
- They'll overtake
your taste buds.
- I'm the candy now!
- [Chris] (laughs) points!
Points, Jenny.
- Double-Stuffed Glory Holes.
- Yes, points.
Todd Barry.
- It Hurts When I Pee-nuts.
- (Laughs) Points, Mike.
- Jizzlers.
- Yes!
You know what they say,
makes mouths happy!
Yes, Neal.
- Purple Vein.
- (Laughs) Oh, oh oh oh!
By Prince Albert, points!
Michelle.
- (Censored) Into My Window.
- Yes, points, Dan.
- Mama Said Suck You Out.
- Points, Neal Brennan.
- Theme From Shaft.
- (Laughs) Points.
Michelle.
- Can't Touch Piss.
- Points, Neal.
- Tangled Up in Pubes.
- [Chris] Yes, points!
- Oh, so gross!
- Dan.
- Wrecking Balls in My Mouth.
- You could've stopped
at 'Wrecking Balls'
but I'll give you points anyway
for going the extra
mile, Michelle.
- Star Spangled Boner.
(applause)
- [Chris] Megan Neuringer.
- H.I.V. Positive bloody marys.
(uncomfortable laughter)
- The crowd is supporting
it, I will give it points.
Yes, Ben.
- Mint Jew-lips.
(laughter)
- Jew lips, Come on!
- Could we, Greg
Proops can you please
this trifecta of offensiveness.
- Uh, sure, Pabst Smear.
- Well done!
A delicious cherry
on top for points.
Megan Neuringer.
- This is gonna
really divide people,
but Shirley Temple Grave Juice.
- Hey, hey hey, you
didn't know her!
(laughter)
Alright, yeah Ben.
- Schlong Island Iced Tea.
- [Chris] Schlong
Island Iced Tea?
- Schlong Island
Iced Tea, come on!
- I'll give you
points for that, yeah.
- [Ben] Come on.
- Yeah, Proops.
- I see your Schlong
Island Iced Tea,
and I'll say Penal Colonic.
(rock music)